So hello everyone.
I'd like to begin by thanking Omar for the lovely introduction and Caroline for
um,
amazing organizing coming up to this.
One of the things Caroline said to me in passing was that there was 69 languages
spoken here in the Google offices and that the average age was 24.
And my initial reaction to that was to feel incredibly old.
Uh,
my secondary auction is what would such a forward looking group,
whether 24 or older,
you know,
would they be interested in the past,
would they be interested in new grange?
So I set myself a task.
What I'm going to try and do in this talk is to speak about a new grange as an
avenue to discussing our shared past,
but also as I have come to believe how new range and the period in which it has
built has things to say to us about today and about the future also.
So to do that,
what I'd first like to do is go back a little bit to my own past.
And really what I'd like to identify is how my interest in the past,
which was for a long time,
just a general interest,
how it turned into something a little bit deeper,
uh,
and something that could speak a little bit more to the future.
So this is my grand old girl's house and I grew up very near here.
Um,
and my grandparents would have been a big influence on me.
this is my grandmother on the left.
Uh,
Florence King.
She would have been born in 1908 on her mother beside her,
Bridget at born in 1882.
So there was a lot of old things around this house.
It was really kind of an island,
uh,
of the past.
So the 1970s and the,
see we're busy modernizing farms all over Ireland,
but somehow this farm seem to avoid all of that.
And it was really a haven of,
of sort of ancient artifacts and plowing was still done with a horse,
believe it or notch hay bales brought in on an old style bogey card.
Um,
and if you were to walk through that door there and the house doesn't exist any
longer,
but when it did,
if you were to walk through that door,
take a left,
you'd be in the main room and turning to the right,
you see a very big open fireplace across that fireplace with large metal beams.
And Potts would have been sat on that.
And if you looked above that again,
you'd see a mental piece.
And it was a metal box containing hundreds and hundreds of beautiful little
colored cards.
So these were sold by cigarette companies and they were kind of a promotional
thing.
Um,
so the idea is there would be sets on everything.
So there could be a set and wild flowers,
um,
you know,
garden tips.
Um,
if it was today,
there would be sets on being a Gmail Ninja or whatever it is.
Um,
one's on,
um,
magical,
uh,
artifacts are amulets.
So you can see here at the scarab beetle on the left or charms.
So we have this,
a prehistoric neolithic stone tool,
which can be mounted in metal.
But this I think was the first time I was introduced to a prehistoric monument.
And as you can see on the left and right here,
there are these ancient pyramids in Egypt.
And of course each of the cards would have a little bit of information,
uh,
on the back.
So here you can see the pyramids are being touted as the oldest buildings in the
world.
No anybody with even a passing interest in megalithic monuments and new grange.
And so on these days we'll hear the oft repeated statement older than the
pyramids.
So we hear this all the time.
And in fact,
many of our megalithic monuments,
we now know to be about a thousand years,
uh,
before,
the great pyramid in Giza was built,
for instance.
So it goes to show that a cigarette smoking isn't the best way to receive an
education.
Uh,
perhaps.
So another way that I became interested in the past was through the landscape
itself.
So this is a critical,
Derek leaves or someone else from County Kildare in the audience here.
And walking down to the river,
Lithia would naturally Passover ploughed fields and you'd end up looking down
and you'd see these objects that would appear in the fields at the time.
Of course,
I knew archaeological training.
Um,
and you know,
I wouldn't have known anything about time periods.
So walking home they may have had a piece of early 20th century ceramic and my
pocket sitting beside a prehistoric stone tool completely on recognized.
Um,
I should say for any view,
game of Thrones fans out there,
any resemblance to bran is purely accidental.
So in this way,
um,
my little childhood hobby sort of mimicked the infancy of archeology and this
was from the 17th century and increasing the up to the 19th century,
antiquarian just collected lots and lots of objects from all over the world.
If you wanted to get an education,
you might go on a grand tour,
you'd go to interesting places,
classical sites,
and bring things back from there.
So you'd find these collections,
everything and anything,
you know,
interesting things from the natural world,
coins,
fossils,
you name it,
sometimes antiquities from the past too.
But they would sit beside each other.
Their age is not known.
Their age is relative to each other,
not known.
And those,
the great antiquity of humankind kind of lay on recognized.
I can't say I learned very much from field walking.
Um,
I did realize it was better to walk a till field and better after rain because
the objects would show up that little bit more clearly.
And I do remember a kind of trance like focus,
uh,
walking across the fields.
One thing that I realized was that the past is all around us,
so especially under our fish.
So even in this building here,
down the road,
um,
was vikings walked here woodkey and say,
yeah,
at the moment there's excavations on James Street on a 12th century church site.
So the past is really all around us.
Uh,
for me it didn't feel like an abstract thing.
It felt almost like part of a continuous and kind of layered present.
But for all that,
you know,
being said,
uh,
you know,
my interest in the past was still a little bit vague,
really probably not that different than,
than most people.
It was kind of a curiosity,
maybe a little bit nostalgic,
something to do with memory,
but that was really it.
But all that changed on the first time I visited new grange here and for those
who,
how many people here have been to new grange or seen a picture of your good?
Lots of people.
That's terrific.
Um,
so I wasn't a child when I visited the sub is about 21 and on a trip out from
college,
and this was just kind of a day out.
And um,
as you can see,
the site has really enormous,
so it's at its widest point,
about 87 meters across.
It's on about half a hectare of land.
So it's an enormous thing.
And as for many people,
probably most of the tourists that go there today,
my overriding thought was how did they do this?
You know,
something on this scale and this sophistication,
you know,
I had grown up on in,
in this,
on the same island and I couldn't imagine my family building something like this
or my local community or the local farmers around about,
um,
or even the town nearby me and quite a large town without modern equipment.
I really don't think they could have won,
you know,
build something like this.
So who,
where are these people?
Where did they come from?
Where they're from here,
or if I'm somewhere else where it was that these were kind of the overriding
questions that I had at that time.
So most of you that have been to new range,
we'll know that it's famous for its winter solstice orientations on the shortest
day of the year,
the sunlight comes down into the money,
but,
but not through the entrance area here as you'd expect through this specially
designed structure above the entrance called a roof box.
And you'll see it a little bit better in this graphic here.
So you can see the sunlight coming from the southeast and shooting down directly
into the chamber.
And even people who go there today and are aware that the sunlight comes through
those,
you still kind of expect it to come through the entrance and kind of slowly
creep up on you inside the chamber.
And they often get a surprise when the guide announces it's there.
You know,
it's,
it's at your feet and it just appears like a laser.
So it's a very,
very striking.
Okay.
So my interest in the past started to change.
After that,
I realized that
what was happening here was something and little bit more vital.
It wasn't just something to do with nostalgia or memory.
It was as if,
for me,
that a part of our story had been lost.
And I sometimes think of archeology in terms of,
you know,
the popular theme in TV and,
uh,
literature and so on.
You sit in a lot of Hitchcock shorts where somebody gets bumped to the head and
completely loses their memory and they sort of wonder around a little bit,
lost for a while.
And then sometimes it's a place or maybe an object.
It mightn't be a particularly big object or a particularly significant object
and all their memories come flooding back in an archeology is a little bit like
that.
It has something of a similar role.
Objects are reminders of who we are,
where we came from,
they help us regain part of our story.
These are some of the typical objects that you'll get in passage.
Tombs like new ranch all around Ireland.
These are from the hill of Tara from a small monument called the mount of the
hostages.
And you've got this unusual pottery called [inaudible] where these uh,
often polished and,
and uh,
why eater,
a beautiful colored,
stolen,
stolen bowls,
pins and personal items often very,
very often burned on the cremation pyre.
So monuments as well as objects they have,
they're all around us in the landscape.
And when you get a little bit tuned into them,
they sort of puncture your reality.
They invite you to pay attention in a different way.
Um,
you realize,
oh,
people have been here before.
Maybe they led similar lives,
had similar experiences,
and maybe our version of reality is a little bit tinner,
uh,
than we imagined.
This is,
believe it or not is a passage tomb also,
but it's one that's quite a bit older than you grains.
So here you can see these large boulder circles,
uh,
or stones in this boulder circle around the monument here.
The central feature of the little chamber has been destroyed.
You can see one stone of it here,
and this is a,
uh,
a crucifix that was erected a good bit later in 1954 to celebrate the Marian
year.
And the clever designers of this housing estate in the 1940s didn't want to
interfere with the monument.
It would be taught to be superstitious,
potentially dangerous.
So they decided to include it in the housing estate.
So sometimes this is playfully referred to as Ireland's first round about,
uh,
first off of many you could say.
Okay.
So on that first day in new grange,
it dawned on me that these were people with a very big vision,
uh,
and they were people probably like you guys,
was an enormous amount of passion,
almost impossible to conceive that would motivate them to construct something
like this.
Um,
and it's sort of set me on a quest.
Who were these people?
Where did they come from,
what could we find out about them?
And that's where we're going to go for the next part of the talk.
So for the next few slides are going to be quite fast and we're going to get
into a little bit of detail on passage tombs.
Um,
so anybody who's had a particularly hard day in the office,
this might be a good time to switch off for a couple of minutes.
Um,
or if you like a pretty pictures,
there's some beautiful photography here,
particularly by a guy called Ken Williams.
And I'll point out some of his photographs.
We go along.
So this is passage tombs over most of our island,
but largely on this line for instead of south Wicklow over to this Slagle Mayo
area and north of that line,
as you can say,
uh,
they often appear singly,
but a peculiar feature is that they appear in little groups,
little clusters,
and we call these passage tomb complexes.
So this is probably the most famous one.
A Bruin.
The bone yet contains new range.
Now doubt about 40 passage tombs,
probably originally lock crew,
less well known about 15 passage tombs there,
maybe 30 originally.
And Cara Keel.
Um,
I'm gonna mention curricula lots,
so just keep a note of where it is there in Sligo.
Um,
a whole series of monuments,
they're 26 or 27 probable passage tombs.
There's no visitor center up there.
There's no guides up there as an amazing place.
You can say it in a passage too,
but not meet anyone for several hours by yourself.
Talk to the gods or whatever it is you'd like to do in your spare time.
And then Kara Moore,
the most westerly of the big passage tomb complex is fairly simple,
small and monuments in a very beautiful location.
And so here are some of the features.
Typically they have a passage and you can see the person who drew this kindly
took the top off so we can see enter the monument.
You often cross these little sill stones.
And then when you get into the chamber there are little side recesses eh,
of,
of the main chamber as you can see there.
And some of these chambers can be quite dramatic.
This is one of these images by Ken Williams.
Uh,
the public can't enter this monuments.
We were very lucky even to see this image.
Um,
and as you can see,
it's a really,
really dramatic location.
Um,
striking art down the end of the monument.
More art here.
And in this case they don't have side recesses.
They have just put a soul stone which demarcates the end chamber.
This is now out west.
So this is one of the sister sites for new grange.
The passage and the chamber are usually covered in stuff.
So in this case,
and typically what you'll get is a coffin of stone and it's a little bit tumbled
down here.
This is a carrot keel.
That location we mentioned already though,
some monuments are covered in there,
may be loose stone and then they have a soil covering over that or chairs.
This is site based.
So this is the boiling river here,
which surrounds new range and all of these monuments.
And this is new grange here behind and you can see it sort of grass covered and
has a white,
a very striking white quartz front at the front of the monument.
All of the sites tend to have a surrounding circular feature.
So here you can see these large big boulders and Archie on worked around the
monument and then the central chamber here,
but many that we'll have these uh,
curb stones that are laying flash.
And at new grange,
this is new grand here,
that between two and five tones.
So you can imagine what's involved in moving those stones.
The largest,
uh,
is over seven times.
Okay.
One of the lovely features of these monuments is that they have art and lots of
us,
uh,
we sometimes think of Ireland as a receiver of influences.
You know,
we get what's coming from silicon valley or from Britain or from European laws
or whatever it is.
But in this period,
Ireland was a Capitol of passive tomorrow.
And we can actually see art that seems to have his home here spreading out to
other places,
such as whales and the Orkney islands and so on.
There's a picture I took,
I think it's my only good picture of this presentation actually.
So I took it about seven or eight years ago in a snowy time at new grange.
And you can see the snow has just brought up,
uh,
the decoration beauty,
and you can see how composed it as,
this isn't the kind of haphazard decoration
we think of kind of one,
um,
type of art.
You know,
when you say to people passes to March and they go,
yeah,
the spirals and the lozenges and so on.
Actually,
there's lots of types of,
sometimes he gets very simple,
um,
uh,
symbols that are sometimes have hazardly placed on the stones.
Uh,
those are then placed together and kind of more compositional ways.
And then also they're removing sometimes art.
So you can say somebody has deliberately pecked away all of the skin,
the outer layer of the stone here.
And that you can see,
those of you would equalize,
might be able to spot there.
Can you see the kind of ghost signature of former art there?
Um,
so we have different kinds of passage tomorrow and he was a kind of modern
world.
They were kind of curating the arch.
So we do,
they were deciding which art was now relevant,
which stones we should maybe reuse,
uh,
and so on.
So it was a very kind of,
um,
in tricky and sophisticated,
activities around the art and procedures around us.
One of the big debates that took place over centuries was,
which were the oldest passage tombs.
They come in different sizes,
so you get large ones like queen waves to,
uh,
in county sluggards about,
30,000 ton monument.
About 60 meters at the base,
a midsize monument here,
a and then sometimes tiny little Darwin.
So people thought,
oh,
maybe we can work out.
Which came first,
was it kind of a sequence of development?
You know,
we're kind of beige passage tomb or whatever it is.
Um,
so some people thought,
no new grange,
thatW and,
and those money was probably the earliest.
And then as they moved further west,
the monuments get a little bit more simple.
You know,
you're getting away from the center of power,
you've last our last astronomical alignments and so on.
Essentially the further west you come,
the more a degenerate at the monuments become an,
you can imagine the people in the west of our and,
and love that idea.
Um,
um,
but,
uh,
another possibility is that the monument started quite simple and there's almost
a kind of competitive construction.
They seem to get a little bit larger and larger as they go on.
And even when you look at new grange itself,
you can see things that key into that story.
So this is the passage leading up to the chamber here inside a new range.
But you'll notice just above us,
you have these crossings stones,
these are roof stones on above those roof stones.
There's remanence of carving.
And I was fortunate enough to get access up into that area.
Above new grange is kind of a secret tunnel.
I'm a professor,
Oh Kelly who excavated the monument,
recorded all of these carvings and you can see them here.
And these were designed to channel water away from the passage and Irish.
So it's a really,
really clever,
clever design.
And this to me speaks of people who were profoundly aware of the strengths and
weaknesses of these monuments.
They knew the things they needed to adjust,
they knew what they needed to to get it right.
You know.
Um,
so a lot of what I've done in my work has been to try and figure out where that
experience came from.
You know,
what,
why are the origins of Newgrange and particularly by looking at passage tombs
nationally all across the country.
Could we figure out that story?
Could we figure out,
uh,
the origins of these builders of Newgrange?
And then we don't have a scale here,
but just to say these are quite large,
you know,
you could roll a quite a large grapefruit down one of those.
So there's an enormous amount of work involved.
So this is one of the first sites that I looked at.
Uh,
this is Kara more already mentioned,
and this is a horse riding stables here,
but you might just pick out some of these circles.
And in fact they're all over this way,
about 30 of these simple little passage tombs.
And two of them we took material from undecided,
decided to date it to see could we figure out the age if these monuments and
correct sort of controversies about the dating there.
So this is one of them here and you can see it a little bit closer.
This is Kara Mora three.
So you have a boulder circle,
you have a small,
tiny little pathway here or a ceremonial sometimes called a symbolic passage.
And then you had a chamber of where the human remains would have been placed and
also little bits of antler and bone that were made into pins.
And you can see some of the pins here.
So myself and a colleague,
Steph and Berg took tiny little bits of those pins and data them.
And to cut a long story very,
very short,
uh,
what we discovered was that two of the monuments there are probably about 500
years older than new grange.
So the passage tombs story in Ireland is a long story and there's a whole series
of developments leading up to Newgrange.
We could see that also here at Cara Keel.
Isn't this just an extraordinary,
uh,
image here?
This is probably the most dramatically situated of the big four passage tomb
complexes in county slog or here.
And we dated material from inside those monuments and not as old as Kara Moore,
but still about 300 years older than your branch.
So we're beginning to trace the outline of a chronological trajectory of the
construction of these monuments.
Another project was open top of Carrick.
He'll here and we found the very first art,
uh,
at Cara Kale.
This is a colleague from the University of Edinburgh.
And to do this work,
he has very,
very fancy photogrammetry techniques.
And a recording methods he uses on the monuments.
So we had to go up in the middle of the night,
uh,
to use these techniques.
So it was really just us,
the bones of the dead,
uh,
officer,
this very wonderful but slightly eerie experience.
OPEC,
Cara Kale.
This is the monument.
And again,
you know,
talking about these striking a limestone karst,
a landscape here,
you can see this monument here and you can enter it.
And when I was in here one day,
it's difficult to see in the light here.
Uh,
but you,
some of you might just be able to pick out hints of spirals there that was just
on a very basic camera.
But when we processed it,
this is what we discovered.
Very clear spirals zigzags underneath and also another piece of art in this
location here.
So finding art in itself is kind of cool.
Um,
but in one way it's not that big,
big a deal all the time.
We're finding new pieces of our,
what's significant about this is that it was the first time art was found in
this whole complex and we could say now for sure that there was art in all of
the four big main passage tomb complexes in Ireland.
And that's helping us a key into the story of development and changes in the art
over time.
So this is another site,
Millan Bay where we've been working and it's one of the largest collections of
passage tomb art in Ireland.
It's almost like a grammar book of passage tomorrow at one of the methods we've
been using as a kind of micro photogrammetry.
So we're literally looking into the Pec,
uh,
of the person's tool when they,
when they hit the stone and it leaves a little peck mark.
And from that we might be able to,
you know,
possibly identify artists who did similar artworks.
So individual artists or,
um,
you know,
see different techniques that we use for different art.
Or we can see how one art crosses another piece of art quiches older.
So,
again,
we're able to see in this story of developments and changes over time.
But perhaps the most exciting project has been here at Kara Keough boons from
here.
We're taking after an excavation in 1911 and they were brought to somewhere
known as the Duckworth laboratory in Cambridge.
And I was looking up to see those bones for the first time in 2012 and myself
and a group of other researchers have been analyzing them since and we've
discovered lots of stuff.
Um,
so we can say for instance,
how many people were here.
This seems to be about 29 people in all of the,
the bones we found.
So these monuments weren't representing the barriers of the whole community.
It was just a very small group of people.
It seems we can say how many men and women that are,
where,
you know,
how many were children,
how many were adults.
Uh,
and we can see a little bit into their lives,
you know,
the kind of diseases they had,
the stresses on,
their bones and so on.
But finally we can also see into their rituals.
And this is proven to be very exciting because it seems there was different
pathways,
different,
uh,
things that happened to you after death,
possibly depending on who you were in society.
We don't know.
One route was that your body could be cremated.
So a pyre would be built,
this is probably quite a public affair.
Uh,
lots of people gathering and huge heats would've had to been achieved about 800
degrees Celsius.
And we could see it on the little bone cause of course very pale and creamy
color when you get that heat.
So it was quite an industrial process almost.
And then after all of that material had cooled down,
maybe after several days you would go and collect these tiny fragments of
cremated bone and there would be placed in the monument.
So that's one route.
Quite a visceral affair.
You can imagine these fires being seen for miles and miles away.
Um,
so very,
very kind of striking thing to be involved.
And anybody who's been to India and seeing the gats Veranasi we'll know that
kind of charge,
uh,
experienced this can be,
but there was another Rouche it seems.
Um,
so some of the bone that we found was on birch and when we look closely at the
bones,
um,
and our osteologists,
Johnny Gabber identified lots of little cut marks on the bones.
So we found about 12 volts now with this and about 90 cut marks and it seems
there was some very unusual,
um,
and sophisticated if slightly gory sounding,
uh,
procedure happening here where the buddies were dismembered.
So we had two different routes,
ways into the other world.
And as I say,
we're still working out.
We don't know on what basis that decision was made and,
but very unusual.
And we could talk about that a little bit more later if you want.
Um,
again,
another brilliant priority of the project.
We have done,
uh,
ancient DNA DNA analysis on age,
individuals from Cara Kale.
Six of those gave us successful results and the work was done by Laura Cassady.
Uh,
we haven't fully published that work,
but I can can tell you here,
uh,
for the first time,
I think that those results are in broad agreement with work that Laura has
previously done here on [inaudible],
a woman up in Belfast and she's a person from a similar period to also buried in
a megalithic monument.
Uh,
so she's a neolithic individual and what it showed that she was of Anatole
Anatolian descent.
So that's largely the area around Turkey and,
uh,
sort of next door to the Fertile Crescent.
You know,
all those areas we hear about in the Middle East,
Lebanon,
Syria,
as fascinating to think Syrian refugees coming to Ireland now.
And our first farmers were coming from relatively similar part of the world.
And we can also say things like that.
Their hair was dark brown.
Typically you're often black.
They had brown eyes,
although variant for blue was also discovered.
So we're finally beginning to answer those questions.
Um,
that I mentioned at the very start of this talk.
Who were these people and where did they come from?
So before gps there was strontium.
If you guys want to find out where somebody being,
you might look at their social media,
where they checked in this,
that,
and the other.
You can't do that 5,000 years ago with what you can do is look at strong diem.
This is quite a complicated thing,
so I'm going to make it very quick.
Stolen.
Contagious contains a trace element called strontium.
When the stone breaks down,
that goes into the soil and it goes into the water,
into the plants,
into the animals,
into us.
When we develop teeth,
it takes up tiny,
infinitesimally tiny amounts of strontium and that can be measured.
And through measuring that,
we can tell the kind of bedrock that you grew up on.
Okay?
You're going to have to take my word first.
It sounds a bit magical,
but it's true.
Um,
so when we looked at the remains of 14 different people,
uh,
from Kara Keough,
we saw the vast majority of the had grown up in the local area.
So there are deep ancestry,
might be the fertile crescent or Anatolia Bush there.
Where they grew up was in the northwest of Ireland.
Curiously,
three people didn't fit that bill.
They seem to grow and open a slightly milder climate may be here or somewhere.
Um,
two of them could have been from elsewhere in Ireland,
would,
one of them appears,
grew up somewhere in central Europe and as has a very unusual signature to the
strontium.
So again,
it just makes the picture ever more interesting.
And this is confirmed by the DNA as well because it's showing that the people
buried in the tombs that we looked at,
they weren't even related,
you know?
So again,
you know,
it's still something we're trying to figure out,
but the story just keeps getting more and more interesting in a way.
So what does all this mean for you guys?
Um,
those,
this Havana,
you know,
could,
uh,
tell us anything about today?
Is that of any relevance to the future?
Going to argue that it is,
and you might be surprised to hear that these people in some ways,
we're in some ways a little bit like you.
So one thing we can say is that we're a very young population.
Um,
I believe this is a prank.
Is it that you guys played on the view camera's going by or something sometime
ago?
I Dunno,
that's,
that's what I'm told anyway.
But uh,
people in the Neolithic,
we're very young.
Osteologists would be a little bit wary about giving,
you know,
averages for the whole of the Neolithic and Ireland or a particular region.
But we know from individual sites,
individuals are often under the age of 30.
It's very common at the first analysis in 1911 off the remains from curriculars
in most individuals around 25 as sometimes women younger than men as an average
age of that.
So they were very,
very young population
also,
as we know from our previous slides that came from foreign lands.
So they probably brought different languages,
you know,
that done that.
Then the people here would have spoken.
They would have had different religious beliefs,
maybe,
um,
different food preferences and different clothing.
Maybe I'm not suggesting this is what you guys were on the weekend or anything,
but,
uh,
you know,
a lot of differences,
a lot of changes there.
We're bringing in new life,
new ways of thinking,
a whole new world view,
really a whole way of proceeding at the world around them differently.
One of the things we know about new grange was that it was a community affair.
It was a collective affair.
So to build the monument of course required lots and lots of people,
hundreds if not thousands of people,
but even just to gather the materials and an enormous amount of people.
So we know some of the materials.
So the white Cortes came from the Wicklow mountains that 70 kilometers to the
south east.
A lot of the other material,
they mourn granites and Yuri granted rights.
They were collected on the north shore of Don Dark Bay.
And some of these enormous stones here,
impossible as it is to believe were brought from Claire her head.
So that's several kilometers out along the River Boyne uh,
and then up the coast by boat,
somehow with a big bolt presumably,
and somehow bringing back these really large stones,
uh,
and then up the slope to new grange or alternatively coming across land,
which seems almost impossible to conceive to through forests.
You know,
over undulating ground,
either way it seems impossible,
but we can say for sure now that's some of that material concert there.
And even some of the courts may come from rocket island here.
It's recently been suggested.
So we knew they were moving by water as well.
So these days we talk about crowd sourcing,
crowd funding,
uh,
these kinds of ideas and clever people have broken down,
you know,
the kind of features and factors involved in that.
So things like collective knowledge,
collective creativity,
community building and innovation,
the kind of stuff you guys have been involved with.
And would,
I'd suggest to you that with a lot of these newer models and maybe new
technologies,
is it possible we're told him returning to very old ideas and older models.
In fact,
one thing we can say that Neolithic people were very good at is in acknowledging
death.
Um,
and it's something that maybe we're not so good at these days ourselves.
So death was very much front and center of Neolithic community.
So this is queen may is too with a very large,
uh,
passage tomb on the top.
And it can be seen for miles and miles around from great distances.
As I said,
the monuments may not have contained a lot of human remains,
a lot of people,
but they didn't need to to serve as an emblem.
Just by seeing this thing from afar,
you had this fairly striking emblem of death and the afterworld,
again,
isn't this another extraordinary picture here by Ken Williams?
This is a new range at night.
Um,
and monuments like Newgrange you could say there were a little bit like momentum
Maura,
you know,
the skull on the medieval philosophers desk,
you'd want to check in and it would remind you of death and what's important in
life,
what's notch.
Um,
so Philly dish and Pangea 1671 created this image and he boils it down to three
things.
We have life,
death and time.
And you could say those three areas are founded new grand.
So a huge life force involved in creating a monument of this scale.
Molting be motivating people to do this work.
Had a terrific emblem of death and the ancestors and the afterworld and also
time through the winter solstice alignment.
You have this kind of centralized,
uh,
captured time if you like,
within the monument.
Another area,
uh,
that they were concerned with seems to be not only the winter solstice but the
turning seasons.
So we have the winter solstice alignment here at new grange,
but there are other monuments that do the summer solstice alignment.
Some do the sunrise,
some do this on sash.
Uh,
there's arguments about it,
but some may also have equinox alignments.
So you can see these people are charting the course of the song all the way
through the year.
And this is a very interesting thing.
You have,
uh,
the cultural historian,
Thomas Berry has talked about our need for a new arts story,
uh,
particularly in the middle of our current environmental difficulties.
And at Newbury.
And here you have kind of an instant cosmic liturgy.
You could look at the art through the year.
You look at the birth and death of the son through the year.
Uh,
and we can supplement that story with our knowledge of the cosmos and the art's
place in the universe.
So you have the cosmological story here in waiting in Newgrange and potentially
important for us going into the future.
Could new grain say something to us about data storage,
transfer of knowledge,
communication I'd suggested could,
so one of the things it did as that we can go to the monument today and if we're
lucky enough to win the lottery,
we can be in there on the day of the winter solstice and see the sunlight coming
into the monument today.
We talk about,
you know,
virtual reality and the potential of that in the future.
Maybe this isn't quite virtual reality,
but to be able to stay stand in the same monument,
in the same chamber and see the sunlight just as Neolithic people did,
you know,
did they deliver their message?
They sure did in an extraordinary way.
We don't know what the art means.
We have lots and lots of good guesses,
but really we can't comprehend it.
But what we can say for sure is that it was delivered.
You know,
it may be in a hundred years,
they're in a thousand years.
It's somebody figures this out and surely it's meaningful.
You know,
when you look at this has to be so many to it,
we can't nail it down.
Um,
but it's,
it's not,
it's not accidental.
It's not haphazard.
This kind of art.
So we can say that they delivered their message and not regard.
And again,
they're precious cargo of the bones of the dead.
This has arrived forward into the future too.
So again,
this is another way,
you know,
we talk about ones and Zeros and maybe people have concerns about the
vulnerability of data.
Here we have an enormous amount of data.
True.
The winter solstice alignment,
true the art through the bones of the dead that's been sent 5,000 years into the
future.
And extraordinary accomplishment.
And again,
there are not their lives for tens of thousands of years at people were hunter
gatherers and new grange can tell us things about the environment and our
relationship to the environment.
Um,
so what happens in the Neolithic is that people settle down for the first time.
And a lot of our modern innovations,
whether it's biotechnology or advanced genetics that come from the types of
things that Neolithic people were doing originally.
So there were domesticating,
uh,
the world around them.
They were harnessing the natural world.
Um,
there were domesticating plants and animals and breeding them and so on.
And it's not that leads directly to our modern genetics and so on,
but arguably has the full crib turned too far in one direction.
So one estimate has it.
When new grange was built,
there was 25 million people in the world.
This is Shanghai.
The population of Shanghai is 25 million people and the Neolithic,
when new branch was built in Ireland,
a very rough estimate that's been thrown out about 150,000 people,
uh,
living in Ireland at that time.
So our populations have increased dramatically.
At the same time,
our animal populations are in free fall.
So surely we need to make some kind of adjustment there.
And returning to the Neolithic,
you know,
the simplicity of life.
Uh,
one thing that we know when the commentators often say is there are monuments.
They're communal buildings.
They put enormous efforts into Ed with their houses.
Sometimes a little bit more modest,
you know,
maybe didn't last as long,
not as visible in the record.
And maybe something that's we need to consider too,
moving away a little bit from the individual or the family and towards wider
communal efforts and maybe to use less resources and so on.
And our building too.
So stepping into the kind of archeological time machine and looking back can be
a way to help us readjust our priorities.
So in conclusion,
um,
I think new grange and this period has a lot to say to us,
for sure.
We can say that they honor their ancestors and they were aware of their past.
They were all too aware of the future,
and they delivered a message successfully into the future.
And
that way they remind us reading,
uh,
you know,
the,
we also need to think about the past.
We need to consider a future generations,
make progressive choices,
uh,
work as one community and leave a good legacy for the people to come.
Can we leave a legacy that is as wondrous as profound and maybe as instructive,
uh,
as the people that built new ranch left doors.
Thank you.
Robert is a fascinating and a beautiful presentation.
Um,
I'm very relevant as well in so many ways that you've made us for us today.
And there are loads of questions that I have for you.
I'm not really sure where to begin.
What thing that astounded me early on in your,
your talk was the number of passage tombs across the country.
Do we know what percentage of them have any kind of astronomical orientation?
Yeah.
You said it's very,
does not just what your soul's just yes,
there has been work done on it.
And this guy called Frank Prendergast from dit and he looked at 138 monuments.
Uh,
that's where it started in good enough condition and that had a passage that
could be measured.
Uh,
and you just go over that.
About 24 of them across the country had some kind of,
um,
relationship,
uh,
with the song in particular.
Nothing to the moon or to the stars or anything like that at all of those.
Some of them might be accidental.
So you know,
in your bathroom at home or whatever it is,
that might be just one room in the house that has particularly good life.
No money in my hands.
It yourselves.
So some of them could be accidental.
There are a little bit off perfect dot kind of thing.
But a rose face.
Small percent.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's interesting and interesting that it's the sun.
It's the song in particular.
Yeah.
The moon is a much more tricky affair.
Oh,
much more difficult to,
to stars as well.
It would be much more difficult even if they had to discover if they were
aligned to a star.
Okay.
That's very interesting.
Um,
do we know who,
um,
who was in the tombs or
why a certain person,
was it like landowners or chief done?
Yeah,
I mean the evidence from Kara Kale is showing,
uh,
is,
is sort of filling in that picture a little bit for us.
And it's difficult.
You can't say it's no obvious group.
It's not just sort of old men.
You know,
the sort of big mound,
the chieftain,
um,
it's not just sort of families or that kind of thing.
There seems to be people of all ages.
Um,
um,
uh,
carer cue,
the osteological analysis said about nine men if memory serves me right and
about four women could be identified.
Um,
but beyond that we really can't say on what basis they were selected.
It's certainly wasn't a whole community.
So if you imagine these sites in use for three,
400 years,
you know,
on some remains maybe put in every year,
tiny,
tiny amount.
It has to be.
Yeah.
Um,
you mentioned in the talk,
I'll just ask more question before I go to audience Q and.
A.
But you mentioned for a new grange how far away a lot of the material was taken
from like some of the taken from the Wicklow mountains then from an island.
Do we have any information details on,
on how that was
nails?
There's theories and so some people would suggest suggest going across the land
is good.
And when you look sort of ethnographically,
uh,
there's examples where people did that and it involved often the chief standing
up on this massive stone has lots of people moved it and he's saying,
I'm an important person,
you know,
and this is how many people I can influence to come and do this project.
And if they didn't like the chieftain,
maybe they might sort of ditch the stoner breakage or you know,
something like that in some cases.
But a lot of people have suggested it was moved by water.
Um,
so there are some kind of tentative evidence of drop stones in the river that
didn't successfully make it.
Um,
and Jolene stowage in particular has looked at a method whereby a stolen would
be tied underneath the bone.
I wonder,
need a bolt at low tide.
And then as the tide comes in,
the boat lifts stone lifts to under good the salt in the water.
It helps make it less of a burden and a,
and moved it that way.
Bush,
you know,
incredibly difficult,
probably dangerous.
Um,
and,
and what an accomplishment to be able to do.
It's just,
it's,
you know,
even as an,
and we know this stuff to say,
it is just extraordinary,
you know.
Go ahead.
Oh,
we do lots of questions from the audience.
I'll pop this on to you there.
Does any of the arts in the passage tombs have human figures,
figures in it or is it all sort of the geometric type designs and that that you
had in the photos?
Yeah,
there are a couple of examples that do look at triple morphic.
They look like human faces and some scholars such as Maricia,
surely one in UCD has,
has suggested some of these might be faces.
It's a very difficult one because even I know myself,
you look at art and we want to see things.
Uh,
the human mind is programmed to see patterns and particularly we've a very
strong kind of obviously for obvious reasons,
the association with the human face.
So we want to see it.
So it's one of these things that's debated or other people have suggested.
You can see sort of snake,
like things in the art.
I possibly trees and ferns.
Um,
but we just don't know,
you know,
beyond getting a time machine and going back with a microphone.
I was getting question.
We probably will never know.
Hi.
Um,
going back to the ID at where you were saying dead,
uh,
it's not everybody for sure that was buried there.
Uh,
I wanted to ask you like if there was traces of other burial places,
like where were the other people buried?
If it was not everybody there and if you could find any clue on how they were
different from the people that was buried in passage.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's funny cause you read archeology books sometimes and you see the show while,
how was that in the Neolithic and the show a picture of a megalithic term,
but we know it was just a tiny percentage of people.
So it's a quick question.
Where were the other people buried?
Now we do,
oh,
of course.
I've mentioned just one type of passage to,
uh,
or what type of megalithic term,
rather the passage tomb,
but that were olders.
So there were other places that people would have been buried.
All so,
but beyond that,
you know,
um,
cremated remains could have been born in a river,
you know,
they could have been buried.
We don't know.
Um,
I was reading recently about rituals and contemporary rituals in Tibet and,
um,
where you look across the world,
you see variation is the norm actually work quite,
um,
narrowed in to Justin burial,
primarily in Ireland and a little bit cremation.
Now when you look elsewhere across the words,
you see lots of different types of things happening in the one society.
So in Tibet you might have sky burial or a,
a body was placed out and uh,
the flesh would definitely,
the body would decompose the flesh with might be taken away by Korean birds.
They would have cremation and they would have burial in humiliation.
The body was placed in the ground.
And then some people also it would be,
uh,
but through water.
So those four distinct methods and it's,
it's possible,
you know,
that there was a similar amount of methods in Ireland.
Oh,
that's great.
Yeah.
Really good question.
Do we have anymore,
another audience question?
Yeah,
just to get the funds.
Thank you for the great presentation.
Very welcome.
My question would be probably not very,
very much related to the,
uh,
to these particular,
grapes.
Uh,
my,
my question is like,
how do we have these things?
So like a distinguishably scene where put an overnight,
why,
why it,
why would they not,
uh,
w with an ob there with a layer of dirt or earth and need and have to be
escalated,
like for example,
in Metro,
like only a certain percent that she's out there.
So is it because of the climate or like what,
what would be the main reason?
Hmm.
Well,
your question points to something very interesting,
you know,
for a burial,
for a grave,
um,
you know,
really all we need is to dig a place in the ground.
You know,
and what several people have pointed out is that clearly what's happening here
is,
requires much greater efforts and Nash,
and is it really correct to call it a tomb at all,
uh,
from that point of view.
So a lot of what's happening here is symbolic.
You know,
that you can see the monument from very far the decoration,
the winter solstice alignment that comes in,
it's suggested was much more here.
This and much more meaning than just about simple burial,
but,
but do think they have been preserved during the ages.
So like,
like different generations,
they tried to not,
uh,
not to make them be being forgotten,
like,
you know,
excavate them,
like taking care of these places.
Well,
one of the things that preserve that would have been a,
there was a very strong superstition around a lot of these monuments and some of
the monuments would have been known as a fairy forwards or and so on.
And people thought,
you know,
you might get,
if you just start with one of them,
you might get ill or Bob Lockwood come to you.
And every single part of Ireland,
there are many hundreds and hundreds of those stories,
you know.
So they certainly protected the monuments for a long time.
Um,
you know,
we have about 1,700,
uh,
megalithic monuments in our,
but there may have been more originate to,
you know,
um,
so some were certainly destroyed,
particularly the smaller ones,
but something like this isn't,
isn't going to be destroyed too easily.
I was just wondering,
has there been any reason sane for the majority of the passage teams are spread
across the northern half of the country?
Or are the other types more evenly spread or is there anything reason for them
to know?
And I would personally love to know the answer to Sasha.
And I tell you,
I haven't even heard a good theory as regard that it is an unusual thing.
There are some certainly to the south and evidence of passenger tradition as far
as out as clear island and so on.
Of course.
Um,
so there were there and Neolithic people were moving all over the island.
No question.
But it is something of a puzzle,
you know,
that's be interesting.
Uh,
I have actually two questions.
One is,
uh,
related to Google and one is not related to Google.
So the one that's,
uh,
I'll start with,
with the second one.
Uh,
you showed some of those tombs,
they're relatively small,
right?
So just a few meters in diameter.
Uh,
so how do you identify that this is actual aerial stuff?
If I go and pick the old rocks and put them in place,
uh,
would you,
like,
could you definitively say that this is a,
you know,
a new markup,
they or a,
or an old thing that was used?
That's question number one.
Question number two.
Are you a or have anybody used Google maps imagery to identify the tombs?
Thanks.
Yeah.
Um,
as regards to the first question,
it is confusing because sometimes people have those,
how does this days,
days and you know,
they'll pull up a very big stone in the foundations and then maybe another and,
and they five looks like a diamond.
Um,
did they make a dull moment in their garden or something like that?
And they can look,
you know,
very similar to answer monuments.
So of course,
we can't take the stolen wait.
We date,
uh,
items that are found within the monument.
And that's what tells us is an authentic one.
Uh,
as well as that,
for many,
many decades and generations,
people have been recording these monuments so we know where all the real ones
are,
more or less,
you know,
so that gets around that problem.
Um,
as regards,
uh,
Google maps and so on.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And,
uh,
you know,
I have colleagues who are up to two and three in the morning and I'll Google
maps,
finding sites,
zooming in on things,
not getting any sleep,
but it's very exciting.
So it's,
it's,
it's been an obstacle brilliant to,
uh,
for finding new monuments or even just presenting information and showing people
landscapes and so on.
Yeah.
Take good questions.
That's great.
Where you have,
we're almost at a time.
So just before we let you go,
uh,
Robert was explaining to me earlier,
heard the name new ranges and to particularly exciting,
but it has a far more beautiful name.
Can you tell us about where blue boy or a [inaudible] and palace,
the palace on the boy,
and then you tell our audience,
uh,
those names came from,
it's just from the Irish language.
Uh,
so the Borneo comes from the boiling river,
which surrounds the whole complex.
And if there was no boiling river,
they'll probably would be no monuments.
So demarcates it is a very special piece of land.
It was associated with the [inaudible].
Um,
and then the word brew is refers to a palace.
Sometimes it's translated or sometimes as a hostile.
Um,
so,
uh,
the hostile on the vine or the pilots on the vine as the proper name,
and it's often associated with the Danish and Angus.
It was a young God.
Uh,
I'm kind of a song,
God as well.
A very appropriately.
That's lovely.
That's a far,
far nicer name.
Thank you so much for your time and for your information on your,
appreciate it.
Thank you.
Okay.